a huge part of a hit reality shows
appeal comes from its colorful cast of
real-life characters who bounce off one
another with a unique chemistry any
Network sitcom would go to war for
that's definitely the case with storage
wars what's the original cast up to
today husband-and-wife team Dan and
laura dotson were the main auctioneers
for the entire run of storage wars their
auction style was marked by classic
fast-talking patter with the occasional
reality TV friendly squabble with a
bitter all right if you're ready to go
I'm ready to go and here we go number 20
what you play a man what do you think
how much now Dan and Laura run their own
private auctioneering company called
American auctioneers they offer up
auctions to the general public
throughout California most of which are
typical legal sales and cease blockers
the couple also runs storage auctions
net which acts as an online database and
facilitator for storage facility
auctions across the country as the blast
reported the Datsuns discovered they had
sold a very special Locker to a client
for five hundred dollars in 2018 what
was inside well seven point five million
dollars in cash dave Hester is the
closest thing the show had to an
outright villain he got into fights with
his fellow bidders and even the
impartial auctioneers he raised the
prices on lockers he had no intention of
buying and he did it all with his
infectiously aggravating legally
trademarked according to USA Today
Hester tried to blow the lid off the
whole operation in 2012 when he
complained to Amy producers that the
program was largely fake when amy fired
him he filed a wrongful termination suit
for $750,000 in damages however the suit
was settled in 2014 and has to return to
the show for the remainder of its run
shut up don't tell me to shut up I'll
tell you to get out of my auction how's
that now he runs an independent business
as an auctioneer and consultant in an
interview with spare foot he said that
his eventual goal would be to buy a
motor home and not even have a home
address anymore and just travel from one
town to the next and be a gypsy
auctioneer known as the gambler' darrell
Sheets made big swings on storage wars
often scoring big he once bought a
locker for a thirty six hundred dollars
only to discover it contained artwork
worth three hundred thousand Hajus man
three hundred
some dollars this was far and away the
biggest profit made on the entire show's
run now sheets is somewhat retired from
public life and clearly enjoys being a
family man alongside his daughter and
his fiancee
he's also undergone a dramatic weight
loss shedding approximately 40 pounds
using the Nutrisystem method
sadly in March 2019 sheets revealed on
social media that he was recovering from
two back-to-back heart attacks after
years of being in his words a closet
diabetic that would eat whatever he
wanted and masked it with diabetic pills
let's hope for a safe and speedy
recovery for the gambler on storage wars
collector Barry Weiss disarmed everyone
with us on Orthodox bidding style and
Ratatat roasts against his fellow
storage warriors he impressed a-any so
much that in 2014 he left the original
show and was given his own spin-off
buried treasure on the show which lasted
for eight episodes he travelled across
the country in search of hidden goodies
and knickknacks showing off his
knowledge of classic cars in the process
the following year he was given yet
another ane spin-off called storage wars
Barry Strikes Back Weiss guided viewers
through his favorite storage wars
episodes and moments offering
behind-the-scenes tidbits along the way
oh here's where they're taking the body
mouth currently Weiss has stepped away
somewhat from public life he hasn't
tweeted since 2014 and a couple of more
recent TMZ interviews Weiss said he
won't be appearing on TV anytime soon
contend with living life as in his words
a professional slacker merry storage
wars journey began on a spinoff after
her stint on storage wars Texas Mary was
brought onboard the main ship in season
five she earned her nickname the junk
stirrer based on her devil-may-care
attitude toward finding treasures today
this bull currently Mary maintains a
vintage store called Mary's finds which
sells as she describes it an eclectic
mix of found treasures refurbished or
untouched many of which were featured in
her personal storage wars journeys
according to her website Mary has also
worked extensively with Ubuntu life an
organization dedicated to helping
children with special needs in Kenya
Mary personally visited Kenya met with
many of the locals and collected
treasures along the way she sells some
of her
mine's on our website with 20% of the
proceeds going directly to boon to life
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]